The answer here, of course it's a bit subjective, but I think from just looking at the strategies
that these 2 algorithms use here, it seems as if the "Greedy" alogirthm
should perfom much better, because it always tries to cover as much as possible
in each round, while this one up here seems almost a bit stupid,
because it just takes any edge and always blindly puts both endpoints into vertex cover.
Although actually just 1 endpoint would be needed to cover that edge.
You may already be guessing that I asked you this question
because I am now going to show you the exact opposite.
Because it's the case that although this algorithm here seems better,
and the strategy appears to make more sense,
actually from a point of approximation quality, at least if you consider the worst case,
this algorithm up here, "Take 2," is actually the better algorithm.